yes
tv
a very warm welcome to one and all
present here we'll be starting with
today's workshop in four more minutes
thank you for joining
you can introduce yourself in the chat
box and let us know about your
educational background and your research
interests as well in the meantime please
thank you
all right so very warm good morning good
afternoon or good evening in whichever
part of the world you are i would like
to welcome you all to the workshop on
metagenomics
targeting human genome microbiome diet
and supplements
so as we all know metal genomics allows
us to discover new genes and proteins or
even the complete genomes of
non-cultivable organisms in less time
and with better accuracy than classical
microbiology or molecular methods
in today's workshop we will explore how
different types of analysis can be used
to understand the microbiome we will
learn to compare microbial composition
in different conditions and see how
various approaches to metagenomic
sequences are used to study bacterial
and viral communities we will do so in
the context of several projects taken
from high impact publication
so today we are going to cover few of
the topics mentioned here on the slide
we will discuss about metagenomic
sequence analysis and also have a
hands-on practical analysis session on
meta genomic data analysis with data two
and kind pipelines on the t by info
server
we will also explore some example
projects on the tbi info server which
includes role of high five diet on
obesity effect of non-antibiotics
and red syndrome and also effect of
dietary fiber intake on microtime
so before we begin with today's webinar
i like introduce us for those who have
just joined us for the very first time
we are a u.s based bioinformatics
company who is working with multiple
academic and commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
the omixlogic training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries and over 300
workshops and due to this past growth
our team is working with local and
regional coordinators that are helping
refine the local program logistics and
leverage our online training resources
adapting them to the needs of students
and researchers around the world
the training has been completed by
participants in six different
specialization tracks which includes
oncology infectious diseases precision
medicine neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omics data analysis
so how do omix logic resources help
advance bioinformatics teaching
comics logic is a portal for practical
and theoretical learning of
bioinformatics it is composed of courses
designed to take you through the
theoretical knowledge comics logic takes
a combination of training modules data
science tools curated project data sets
and interactive sessions with mentors to
give a student a clear path of the
bloom's taxonomy pyramid and no matter
what the user's initial experience is
bio info with bioinformatics comics
logic is a useful tool for gaining a
baseline knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics
and also learn about analysis of large
data sets get an introduction to basic
coding languages like r and python for
biomedical data analysis and beginning a
data analysis project altogether
the registrants of the workshop will get
the access to the omixlogic courses
which includes the courses on
bioinformatics precision medicine
multiomics which includes genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and
ecogenomics as well also data science
that includes bioinformatics using r and
python you will also get the access to
example projects or in different fields
of the omics data type that i just
mentioned which you could learn from and
replicate your research for
the users will be given directions to
access the divi info platform for
bioinformatics processing and analysis
of transcriptomics data the platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management and analysis cloud
infrastructure to run bioinformatics
pipelines different stages of analysis
are performed in different sections of
this multi-omics platform
so first of all let's begin by signing
up on the omixlogic learn portal please
make sure that you have a complete
profile once you have successfully
signed in a complete profile will have a
profile image
full name with appropriate
capitalization
link to your social media handles which
could include facebook linkedin
instagram or kid and twitter and a brief
bio about yourself that will consist of
educational background and research
interest
the mentors can view your progress under
the activity tab that is there in your
profile the courses that you currently
are completing will appear under the
courses tab and finally the completion
of your course the certificates will
appear under the certificates tab
so that was a simple introduction about
us and who we are and also how you have
to get started by signing up on the
omixlogic learn portrait i'll be
resharing my screen now and i'll just
quickly give you all a demonstration of
how you have to get your free account on
the omixlogic learn portal so that you
can learn about the resources available
and leverage from them
so those who already have their accounts
on the portal please put a one or yes
maybe in the chat so that we know that
you are good to get started with uh
today's session and those who are new
i'll just share the link in the chat box
please make sure that you sign up today
we are going to practice some of the
pipelines as i mentioned in the
beginning of the workshop itself and to
practice these pipelines you have to get
the access to the metagenomics
coursework and also some of the example
projects so for the workshop we have uh
unstarred few of our lessons of the
practical hands-on analysis
that will give you a guideline to run
the pipelines for data and kind too and
also some of the our lessons have been
unstarred for the workshop attendees so
that you can practice some of the r
scripts along with the mentor today in
the session itself and after the
workshop you can take up the starter
subscription that will help you complete
your code block and run the analysis and
get the full access of the material
so now let me quickly give you a
demonstration of how you can sign up on
the omixojic learn portal the link is
there in the chat box i'll just simply
click on the login button on the extreme
right side now i can login where any of
my social media accounts or create an
account for myself
i'll be opening the google option where
i'll be using one of my google accounts
to sign up on the omixlogic learn portal
so
um it'll take a while me but you can
also sign up so that you are all set to
practice the code block and run the
pipeline uh with the mentor today in the
session i'll be just taking few minutes
before i pass on the session to dr
raghav to take the session ahead so you
can click on any of your google accounts
and get started
i awaited the responses in the chat box
if you have signed up please put a one
or yes in the chat
so that i know that we are all set to
begin
and
after you have successfully signed up on
the onyx logic learn portal please make
sure that you have a complete profile a
complete profile is a portrayal of all
your achievements which includes the
courses you have completed the projects
you have submitted the programs you have
completed so it will help you um in your
recruitment process
all right so that was it that i wanted
to discuss about and now i just pass on
the session to dr raghav to get us
started with today's workshop over to
you dr raghav
thank you
let me find ways to share my stream and
until then you can confirm my audible
and
my screen is visible
uh so you are audible to us
it's not yeah and you can see your
screen now thank you okay perfect
so hello everybody so welcome to this
free webinar on metagenomics human gut
microbiome and diets of diet and
supplements so today we are going to
understand
how um
how to study microorganisms in the
natural environment
how to understand their functional roles
in in
in many areas that are related to human
health and human diseases right so um
we will also discuss
we will focus specifically on the
bioinformatics data analysis of the meta
genomics data and we will focus also or
we will
discuss on how to perform this analysis
in a completely code free environment
and also
in
predominantly r and python leveraging
some of the uh tools that
our pythons functions uh inbuilt
functions and libraries provide us with
so until then
let's quickly uh until you sign up let's
quickly get a headphone of how many of
you are aware of how to run
at least four or five lines of code in r
or python so if you know
r just type r and if you know python
just type python if you
have
an introduction or exposure to both the
methods just type r and p or rm python
okay can i get some responses here
i'm monitoring your chat so if you have
any questions until then just quickly
respond to us and
as analica mentioned we will be
leveraging some of the
shareable collaboratory notebook from
google collab so if you have google
account it's it's good idea to
sign up
sign in to the google account and keep
it signed in
in chrome or any other browser of your
choice so just let me know if you
have
exposure to r and python
or none of them
so that's okay it's okay that's why we
are going to discuss how to perform this
analysis in a code free environment
also
thank you
thank you you can see some of the
responses thank you
excellent
it is not a requirement to do this
because uh we are providing you with
some of the codes but it it's an added
advantage if you know some of them and
i will show you what the advantages are
and and i will also show you how to
perform this analysis without any
introduction to our python itself so
let's move forward and discuss uh from
the
from the
theoretical and understanding point of
view how meta genomics are going to help
us understand
our diseases and our human health in
general
so in this webinar in general you will
also learn about some of the upcoming
meta genomics program and that will be
starting soon and beyond these online
programs are actually designed to be
equally rewarding to both students and
faculties and experienced researchers
and it is especially suited for those
who love project first project-based
learning on a flexible schedule
this program will actually cover main
aspects of metagenomic sequencing
analysis of 16s rrna sequences and other
aspects of microbiome research using
bioinformatics so at the end of this
program all the participants will will
be
equipped to conduct independent research
of group projects analyzing data from
public domain learning from high impact
biomedical publications that
specifically talk about or involve
microbiome and microbial analysis the
dynamics
so as in all of our ah training programs
we will also use and leverage online
interactive sessions we will use
self-guided study materials that have
been carefully prepared and designed
with
several practical assignments and you
will get some of the introductions to
what these practical
publication oriented
lessons are
and also we uh we also provide you with
uh
three
streamlined uh
analysis approaches that involve code
free analysis approach and that involved
analysis specifically focuses on r and
python independently
so let's uh let's start with uh
with understanding
what is meta genomic sequencing data
right and before uh
jumping into the analysis of this method
dynamic sequencing data and let's
generally see how
sequencing technology has helped us
study microorganisms and data analysis
tools that are developed for
metagenomic studies are used to
characterize
microbiota and help us understand and
ask important questions about these
microbial communities
so since the discovery of microscope
humans have been learning about
microorganisms that surround us at the
resolution uh surround us right as the
reservation of understanding these
microscopes improve uh
more and more representatives of the
unseen world have been discovered the
scale of this resolution can reveal
details of up to one micrometer which is
a typical size of a bacteria
today these microscopes are tremendously
powerful and that helps us see
smaller and smaller elements that reveal
how the world of microorganisms function
on every imaginable surface and is
actively interacting with each other so
in this picture you can see super high
resolution achieved using uh using
helium technology that shows the
processes of bacteriophages that are in
green which attack the bacteria which
are in bro
so the connection generally between the
diseases and microorganisms has been
established since 1900 so it is and
already towards the end of the 19th
century laboratory methods for doing
these microbes or microorganisms in lab
culture were developed and this helps us
in characterizing them with straining
and with other
other methods
the studies that provide us uh these
studies uh provide us with important
information about the function of the
bacteria in isolation but however it was
soon realized and it was soon understood
that most of the microorganisms live in
complex communities and today we know
that these microorganisms or the
microbiota
that make up the human microbiome are
not just a bunch of unicellular
organisms living alongside each other
but they are highly regulated highly
structured and functionally organized
communities that attach to the surfaces
and
and exist in collaborations with the
with our
human gut
yeah with our uh
with
okay with our human right that
contribute to the ecological stability
so the stability of these micro uh
organisms is fascinating as many of us
probably know
that from trying to battle some common
skin conditions like eczema dry skin or
acne right these uh
communities that form uh distinct groups
of these microorganisms are
interconnected and are determined to uh
determined and and exist in uh
in uh symbiosis or the dysbiosis with
our
skin so the bacteria within a biofilm
can actually communicate with each other
but producing and detecting and
responding to a small molecules are
which are and termed as named as signal
molecules in a process called quorum
sensing or
this can actually benefit the host
colonization this can actually help the
biofilm formation this can actually
help in in maintaining a difference
against competitors in difference
against our adaptation to changes in the
environment that can uh
that can increase in the stress to our
skin or to any condition that these
micro vitamin microbiota offer us
so that is it is estimated uh that human
microbiota consists of around uh 10 to
the power of 13 or 10 to the power of 14
number of microbial cells and with
around
one is to one ratio of microbiota cells
to human cells ratio
so
these numbers are actually derived from
the total bacterial cells in colon only
right specifically only the colon
which contains something around
3.8 into 10 power 13 number of bacteria
so this colon or human gut is the organ
that harvests
harbors
most number of
microbes or densest
microbes
we have right so however each one of
these organisms carry extremely
important functional properties in genes
that that contain genomic information
these properties and the information or
genomic information about these
microorganisms have been of growing
interest to the scientific community and
this has actually produced over 80 000
publications that focuses on the impact
of this microbial community and their
and human health right majority of these
studies are actually focused on
microbiome that exist in the gut or
intestinal microbiota
so however since the 1900s microbiome
studies were significantly advanced
through such major initiatives like
metagenomics of human intestinal tract
and human microbiome project and huge
studies around the world have been made
possible through advances in
metagenomics the sequence
so
as a result of these efforts uh skin
lung gut even brain microbiota is
starting to be characterized and
and and beginning to be related uh
beginning to uh make relevant relations
and relevant uh understanding to the
human disease and
different conditions
so we have several of these projects
that involve understanding the effect of
microbial population in the respective
diseases and we have specific projects
like
alzheimer's gut microbiome project which
involves studying the effect of
dysbiosis and symbiosis which is just
difference in the number or the
abundance of microbial population
compared to the normal and healthy
subjects or healthy healthy
persons
and their effect in
in the onset early onset or the
development or
development or
progression of alzheimer's disease and
some of the generalized
repositories like american gut project
and nih human microbial project involved
understanding the microbial population
of several people and and
which will help us
generally in the comparative analysis of
microbial
abundance across the different
population and different ethnicity
different groups that we can try to
understand
so today we know that
the endogenous human microbial
communities contribute to critical
metabolic physiological and
immunological functions that include
differentiation and maturation of the
immune system that that will include
digestion and addition by food digestion
and
energy generation and the nutrition in
general and this will also include a
metabolic regulation and control of the
fat storage generally and this will also
uh
include and
processing and detoxification of some of
the harmful environmental chemicals and
we already spoke about maintenance of
skin and mucous are barrier function
which acts as a protective film
and this also includes development and
regulation of the immune system and fine
tuning of the immune system's reaction
pattern to several of the
pro-inflammatory and anti-inflammatory
signals
this also includes prevention and
invasion uh prevention of invasion and
growth of disease promoting
microorganisms and by offering
colonization resistance against these
microorganisms from the beneficial
microbes that live in our human
sense among the human cells so many of
these questions are being answered using
the
next generation sequencing techniques as
well as the mass spectroscopy approaches
for understanding specifically
proteomics and metabolomics of the
samples
so in this
world in this specific context we
wanted to
understand how meta genomics which
refers to both the research technique
and research field can be defined or can
be beneficial in understanding or in
studying the microbial dna from a
different environment
so metagenomics tools enable uh
population analysis of
some of the microbes which are
unculturable that that is where we have
uh tremendous advantages of uh next
generation sequencing based or genomics
based approaches to study
previously unknown microbes or
previously uncharacterized microbes
so far so this is very very important as
as we know only around one to two
percentages of bacteria can be cultured
in the laboratory right and the ability
to identify microbes as we spoke about
without without a prior knowledge is
what um
prior knowledge of what actually we have
it in the sample or what actually the
sample contains is actually enabling us
to understand um or enabling us to
new disciplines like microbial ecology
or biology microbiology in general
environmental science and biomedical
research etcetera etcetera
the sequencing based examination of the
metagenome actually has become extremely
powerful too
for generating new and novel hypotheses
that involves the connecting microbial
population to several of the disease
state that we already briefly touched on
so metagenomic sequencing can be applied
to the environmental culture free
sequencing to study population as well
as detailed extraction of the
genomic variation and its expression of
microorganisms after culturing in the
lab and often ah often times such as
these techniques are actually combined
to produce
so uh in a culture-free environment we
we actually
try to focus on the specific genomic
portions of these microbial
counterparts are bacterias or virus that
we will discuss shorter
so we actually use a technologies that
describe
understanding the human microbiome
mainly using next generation sequencing
technologies like shotgun metagenomics
or
on
16s
genomics or that also can be extended to
understand meta transcript problems
so the main difference between uh
shotgun metagenomics and the 16s
amplicon metagenomics is based on the
based on what has been amplified and
what has been
produced in amplification to study there
is a marker cheats
for example in the sixteenth amplified
meta genomics we
amplify or we try to see we sequence
conserved marker regions are the whole
concept g of the 16 is ribosomal rna
gene that is present in all the bacteria
and all the organisms and so forth
and in for example in the meta
transcriptomics and shotgun metagenomics
we try to understand the genomics or
transcriptomics of all the
yeah the whole genomics or a whole
genome or whole transcriptome of the
microbial organisms which will
help us understand the functional
annotation or functional
understanding of these
of these um
microbial uh population so while sixteen
samplicon uh or uh
sixteen s rrna amplicon sequencing will
help us uh
understand or estimate the abundance
levels of these microbial population
for different samples or samples under
different phenotypical conditions or
samples under different disease state
compared to the healthy state the
metagenomics or meta transcriptomics
will actually enable us understand the
functional aspects of these bacterial
population
by relating that to the
metabolomics we can also understand
their efforts in uh
regulating rn uh using some of the
metaboloids as the signal molecules are
some of the beneficial metabolites that
will help us
counter or help us maintain the
symbiosis in our
healthy state
so
focusing on 16s metagenomic sequencing
it is a technique or it is a rather
recently developed technique that is
widely used to study microbe microbiome
directly in its environment so such
sequencing focuses on either 16s
ribosomal laravel rna or 18s ribosomal
rna that has to be amplified using pcr
techniques and these gene sequences uh
six units uh rna sequences contains
hypervariable regions that that will
actually provide species specific
signature um which is extremely useful
which is used to identify these
bacterial taxa depending upon
owing to their differences in
different species and different
classes and different genes
so how are these actually achieved these
are achieved actually in by grouping
these sequences into
operational taxonomical unit which is
defined as um
as closely related individuals or
sequences that arise are that that are
part of closely related individuals so
the similarity or the identity level of
these
sequence relatedness will actually help
us understand or help us characterize
this microbial population into
individual taxonomic unit which may
contain predominantly one species of
microbe or
[Music]
some closely related species of macbook
that share extremely uh identical
16s rrna sequences uh in the hyperbolic
regions
so we use clustering algorithms
that will
that can actually
use hierarchical clustering and other
clustering methods to
combine these otus together so that we
can
address these
bacteria in terms of their taxonomic
units not in terms of their species and
and rather
another layer of identifying which
species are or which
taxonomic
ranks relate to these taxonomic units
actually come from
taking
these sequences that are from
separate otus and trying to identify
their respective taxonomic information
for the domains of bacteria archaea
eukaryote etcetera etcetera so this is
obtained from this from this silva
database which is a ribosomal database
that primarily contains uh
16s rrna or 18s rrna4
for different phylogenies that includes
properia and eukaryotic
so the taxonomic rank information for
these taxonomic units will actually be
identified from
from this database and
and
by comparing this database with the
otus that we
that we characterized from our
from our
sequencing data we can actually relate
that to uh which genus or which fiber or
which class of bacteria or microbes that
are prevalent in specific set of samples
compared to the healthy or normal
samples
so
so far we have been discussing generally
about understanding or how to
use
ngs sequencing for
for the
abundance calculation of cut microbiome
generally but that is not the only place
where microbial community live right
there are specific microbiomes that
coexist with their host and and these
are all extremely vital for our health
and and
they include areas like skin that we
spoke about they include areas in colon
stomach even lung and brain that we also
uh spoke about so the studies that offer
important insights into how these
microbial communities function and how
these microbial ah composition are
linked to different force conditions are
um
are
the ones that are extremely useful in
understanding their contribution to uh
tackling different diseases
so this is this is an example from the
silva tree viewer which is uh
which you can explore
for understanding how different groups
or how different
taxonomic ranks of these databases the
taxonomic banks of this microbial
population is actually organized into a
tree of life or into a tree since this
predominantly or this only uses
sixteenth rna sequences and
we can actually see
which microbes or which ones are
extremely close and which ones are
really far away this is just for
demonstration purposes if you are
interested in ah
interested in checking these uh geo of
life or silver tree viewer please go to
the silva database and you can get
access to this
and so far we have been discussing only
one part of the microbial population
that's predominantly about bacteria but
why rome is also another part of
microbiome which
which is very important to us right
which constitutes all of the organisms
that inhabit us that includes um
[Music]
yeah uh that includes
viruses that may
that may be uh harmful for us
the generally more more and more focus
has been uh
more and more focus is being showered or
more and more studies are focused only
on the
bacterium if we can say that
as understanding how they are beneficial
to us but
generally the effect of viral mean
mammalian physiology or diseases is not
is not very well explored or is
something to be explored
so
some of the publication of this specific
publication actually mentions
the number of viruses that is present in
inside a human microbiome or present
among the human microbiome may be 10
fold higher than what has been estimated
before so
human feces alone contain something
around 10 to the power 8 viruses per
crap so um
our knowledge in understanding the
effort uh understanding the effect of
mammalian viral has to be continuously
updated and and we
[Music]
we must also focus on understanding the
y rooms and their effect in
either maintaining the symbiosis
dysbiosis of this microbial population
should be studied
in detail so this is some examples of
how how different viruses are and their
prevalence and the abundances are
actually seen in
in the human
i think this is from the gut sample
yes this is
this is from the gut sample
so you can see
that so many of these viruses are
actually
highly prevalent and highly abundant in
the in the samples even though
even though they are
they are from the samples that are
generally healthy individuals and
individuals who are not suffering from
any specific diseases
again a snapshot of
i actually start to care again a
snapshot of
how different projects and how different
repositories are actually helping us
understand their connection between
microbial population and
human diseases
so
so to uh
to more understand uh to more discuss
about a better effect actually in the
early development of uh of our uh
developmental stage or human uh humans
uh species in general we actually
encounter our initial gut microbiota in
extremely early early life right most of
the studies actually
for
for at least understanding human
microbiota focuses on um
and this focuses on the studies and on
the colonization that that is produced
after birth and
yes
and during the development of the
diseases but some of the studies have
have led to the hypothesis that a
colonization actually begins in the
uterus and um
this actually provides evidences from uh
these provided evidences as a
supplementary information from placental
microbiome in healthy pregnancies and um
and also by comparing it with the
microbiome of
of unhealthy unfortunate unhealthy
childs or childs with some developmental
disorders we can understand the effort
effect of this one specific study
actually try to understand the effect of
microbial population from from the
placental ah samples on their
involvement in ah the development two
stages of the
babies or human
infants
i mean although
ah there is a question how can we do
virum analysis from shotgun metagenomic
sequencing data
unfortunately i don't think that is
going to be possible mr nalani because
um
[Music]
16s rrna is is i for most of the virus
that is not part of the part of their
sequences for understanding why rome
analysis we have to
do a full uh
meta genomics or meta
there is no point in using neutral
transcriptomics but metagenomic
sequencing
because
most of the viruses will actually that
insect
human host or any other organisms will
hijack the hosts
cellular machinery for their
protein production so i don't think they
are going to carry these rrna sequences
in their genome so uh shotgun
auto genomic sequencing
will be helpful but not amplicon
sequencing this might be helpful yes
shotgun metagenomics or meta
transcriptomics is going to be uh useful
yes i misunderstood your question
so from this specific study in in search
the authors actually concluded uh that
there is actually insufficient evidence
until date to support the
in utero colonization hypothesis and
because the studies actually lacked
appropriate controls that is devoid of
contamination or that there is divide of
confounding factors right but more and
more uh
studies are actually trying to
understand the development or early
development of microbial in in human
infants from the zero to three years and
and how they are related to
for example
onset of different diseases or
how they are actually related to
allergy uh development of allergy in in
uh in human uh child and etcetera
etcetera you can find lots and lots of
uh
helpful um
publications in this generation
so uh
in adult microbiome generally we we know
uh this uh from several of the
publications that
in and also in the human microbiome
project the effort is to relate or to
define or to understand rather let's say
what constitutes a healthy
symbiosis symbiotic microbial
abundance
with respect to
healthy individuals in terms
in terms of a good body mass index and a
good exercise frequency and and good
lifestyle and good dietary habits and
etc etc so this
balanced microbiota population which is
called as symbiosis or biosis um
on a healthy individual with
with
unintentionally or with a good exercise
frequency or how they are defined in uh
in this human microbiome project will be
compared to unbalanced microbiota or
rather which is defined or called as
dysbiosis as as often seen in a
individual with the disease condition
individual with early onset of
diabetes obesity related chronic
diseases and
etc etc and nowadays
we will speak about that but there is
this gut
brain axis
which relates the microbial population
to uh to the early onset of neurological
disorders like parkinson's and
alzheimer's and etcetera etcetera and
there are also other studies which which
we know that relates to um
how for example in current scenario how
the effect of covid uh 19 viruses
infection can be different
to different people based on their
microbial population that harbor the
alveoli cells
so uh
we we will speak about enterotypes but
generally there are
there are bacterial populations that are
beneficial to us uh like bacterias
these are actually classes of bacteria
and bacteria ideas and um provotella and
and
purpose and some of them are extremely
beneficial to us and some of them uh you
will find they are actually not so
beneficial
to us
so uh
what is often under appreciated in in
several of this condition is uh
i have another question let's take that
and move forward what's the effect of
kobe 19 affected mother to their baby
and said
that i don't know mustac maybe that is
not a specific uh
area of study but you can you can find
out if such a study has been done uh
because the sample size
uh of
uh trying to find a covid19 infected
mother and
her
influence on the baby inside the uterus
is actually very difficult to obtain so
i don't think such a study actually
exists so i was talking about generally
the development of microbiol population
or microbiome in a baby uh which can
actually derive their sources from
placental origin uh from their mother
and there are a couple of studies that
do that that's that and i was
referring to that so yeah so there are
for example
many programs that are designed around
cancer to study the role of viruses that
pose a tremendous risk to cancer
development and complicate the treatment
of cancer in general right for example
this ebv virus which is called as a
human gamma herpes virus is one of the
most common viruses in human right it is
best known as a cause of the um
glandular fever or also also
mononucleosis right so it is also
associated with various
non-malignant
and pre-malignant uh lymphomas and and
uh
and
uh
some malignancies in gastric cancer and
and and in and in uh
head and neck cancers and etc etc
and these diseases or these cancers are
also associated with uh
with viruses like hiv and uh
and
another virus is like uh
leukobact leukoplakia and these viruses
actually uh might affect the central
nervous systems in the lipoma so these
viruses are also associated in the
childhood disorders of uh
some material disorders and and some
specific disorders like alice in
wonderland syndrome and and there are
also some evidences and higher risk
developing
higher risks
for
for certain um infants developing
specific autoimmune diseases like uh
systemic lupus inflammation and
rheumatoid arthritis and sclerosis and
etc etc
so these there are about something
around 200 000
cancer cases per year that are that
counter weak that can be attributed this
to this specific uh
epstein-barr viruses are eb
so
as we discussed earlier the effect of
birom and their
contribution in creating a dysbiosis in
our
in our body should not be
counted down or should not be ignored
so these are some of the generalized uh
applications and the applications of
metagenomics data and and
this is specifically for you to
get an introduction to
what are the different areas
metagenomics is generally been applied
to and
what is the data that is actually
produced
to study these specific
conditions right for all of these
conditions uh
as we discussed in one or one or two
slides earlier um the main data that is
actually produced is the next generation
sequencing data that focuses either on
the 16s ribosomal rna gene as such which
is around um
somebody can give the length of the gene
which is around 1 1000 something 200 uh
nucleotides yeah and
sometimes there are most of the times um
when studying large number of samples
a specific hyper variable regions like
v3 v4 and other variable regions are
actually focused uh
for these yeah
are actually focused uh
yes thank you chaudhary is 1.5 kb yeah
so they're actually in
to focus
which is termed as amplicon sequencing
because they are amplifying only
certain regions or certain hypervariable
regions of the
rrna
genes in gene in specific
but
as as other questions actually came from
um
from the only generation they to
understand some of the uh
microbiome uh which is not characterized
uh as per sixteen as higher on the gene
right sometimes these are not part of
the silva database or sometimes these
could be from
extremely rare cases like
samples from
samples from really
from high toxic environment
environmental samples and and samples
that are not generally been studied from
plant samples and etc so for these um
shotgun metagenomic sequencing data
which sequences the whole of the genome
of all the microbio uh population
involve microbial
microbiome involved will be very very
helpful and that is not um
in addition to understanding the
abundance level in such
uh such samples we can also try to
relate
these samples or these
microbiota to their functional
importance in maintaining the symbiosis
or in uh in their effort in
understanding the
understanding the effect and and also
importance of certain metabolites
that they
act upon
so if you have any questions until now
and this is a good time to ask before we
move on to some of the uh demonstration
slides where i will be demonstrating or
where i will be showcasing what are the
different uh resources that we have in
omixlogic platform that will helpful
that will help you
uh in understanding or in performing
these studies yes sarah any free cloud
service for large files of microbial
studies
i am not very sure about free cloud
service any cloud service that is going
to help you in understanding such
analysis of large files of ngs oriented
data and acceleration sequencing data is
not going to be free and even if they
are going to be free and then they are
going to be
there is going to be lot of restriction
in them
and you have to wait for
sufficient resources to come up so that
you can uh perform your analysis so you
cannot wait for six months to perform
one data analysis so i don't i'm not
very
familiar about free cloud services but
there are cap services if you
uh yeah if you want uh you can actually
take a look at herbert bioinfo platform
so uh
we
as an alika mentioned offer you
several of these analysis methods when
code free environment also also code
oriented environment also if you are uh
confident in coding etc
okay let's
move forward for some practical examples
right um
so yeah let's yeah some of let's keep
these slides and and go straight to yeah
um
that is okay chaudhary actually
mentioned some of the
let me find i think there is a
restriction in how you can
interact
i'm not sure about these services so uh
you can explore this is specific to
zara's uh
uh question that how they actually
mentioned okay so uh
now our first focus is on understanding
the effect of
non-antibiotics generally right
and their relation to red syndrome and
what is their relation to red syndrome
and what is red syndrome we will discuss
in a couple of uh
in a couple of slides and
this is specifically to help you
understand or to help you
realize how
sexiness metagenomics sequencing can be
a sixteenth meta dynamic sequencing data
analysis can be performed in a code free
environment
and which will give you a maximum number
of customization that you want to
involve with your or that we want to
employ to your data so let me stop
sharing my
presentation and start sharing my screen
and reshare again
give me a couple of seconds
there is this
stop share
oh
certainly it's
so let me know when you can see my
screen because it started sharing it's
working on
sharing this
where is this
okay failed
can you see my screen i have opened the
project 19 on omix logic platform
which has
yeah effect of non-antibiotics in red
syndrome
can somebody confirm that you can see my
speed
[Music]
thank you very much okay
in this specific example project right
we will actually learn about uh
first we will actually discuss uh how
some of the drugs which are not
targeting
bacterial population may also end up
affecting the
community in general right that is what
we wanted to
focus on in the first part of the lesson
right the main understanding here i will
not go over everything but
that is this
i'm looking for yeah yeah the main
understanding is that we take several
drugs for several different disorders
and several different
ethics right and what this study
actually does is it collected all the
drugs like
156 antibacterials and then
they were actually tested for their
effectiveness in
creating a dysbiosis or creating a
generally
an imbalance in the
bacterial population in colon
specifically right and from stomach to
colon right from different areas so that
is what they found so that is what they
did so what did they find so they found
out of several different antibacterials
how do they term this antibacterial
these are untargeted
non-targeted antibacterial they are not
antibiotics antibiotic will actually
kill most of the antibacterial bacterial
population these are all drugs that we
take for our well-being but
these materials somehow end up being
detrimental to
most of the bacterial species that
reside in our microbial
communities and environment so they
found out that 78 percentage were
actually active at least against against
at least one species so which is a
really um
not very good sign so what it actually
tells and
gives us is
several of the drugs that we take will
end up affecting
the microbial population that we have in
our gut so it is common to experience
digestion related syndrome after several
i don't know whether publication exist
or not but it's a general experimental
evidence
that if you take a lot of painkillers
you are you are expected to develop lot
of digestion related problems and this
could be or could not be related to
microbial depletion or disburses in
microbial i don't know whether such
study exists or not that will be that
will be an interesting
thing to look for so this
in
establishment to this we also have for
example they also have
found out
generally what are the
good
bacterial types that help us in
maintaining the
symbiosis and maintaining the human
health right
these beauty rate producers propionate
producers and bacteria that are specific
to these producers and this publication
gives us a long list of these members
they are very helpful in
understanding or helpful in aiding
digestion and helpful in maintaining the
maintaining the symbiosis of our
human gut and digesting digestive tract
and that is also enterotype clusters of
bacteria which is which is which is
known and
and known to be very beneficial and
and are very stable and and yeah there
are several studies that
specifically uh
mentioned bacterial identities
that we spoke about and they are very
helpful for us in um
[Music]
in maintaining the despair in
maintaining the symbiosis and they are
also part of some of the probiotic
supplements that you will take in terms
of
in terms of requirement so this is
this study establishes and also
provides us some
list of
bacterial population that
that are key to maintaining
symbiosis in our healthy
body so let's go back and what is its
condition what is this relation to uh
something like a red syndrome
right
right the red syndrome is actually a
developmental disorder that focuses on
on
brain or neuro neuro developmental
disorder right it is um
[Music]
it
early onset of these disorders in in
babies are really very very uh difficult
to counter and
and several relationships and several uh
studies focuses on this syndrome is um
yeah um
have actually led to understanding of uh
specific mutation and specific
expression patterns of ah for example
genes like mecp2 or mecp
one and
several isoforms of these genes right
but other results also relate to
microbial dysbiosis of red syndrome
patients compared to normal patients so
this led to
another study which focuses on
understanding the meta genomics or
understanding the microbial um
abundance of uh red syndrome patients
compared to normal uh so um
this specific uh study
right they actually found or they
actually uh sequenced uh fecal uh
microbial uh population and also they uh
sequenced and they
characterized microbial metabolites of
red patients rtt patients under
unrestricted diet right
and how they
interact or what are the dominant
phyla or family that are identified from
ah from there
from these patients so by trying to link
these two and understand
which
group of bacteria or which phyla of
bacteria
are
and and whose abundance levels are
actually related to um
related to the uh
to creating dysbiosis and that's
impatience we can actually try to see if
we can
relate
this finding with the earlier finding
which
generally gives us a list of bacteria
that are beneficial to us and how the
abundance levels of these beneficial
bacteria vary in these red syndrome
patients um
etcetera etcetera so these relationships
and these uh
stud these
comparisons and contrasting can be made
by
by obtaining the data from these
specific
publication and there are
lessons in the course
metagenomics course which focuses on how
to obtain these data from publicly
available resources so this will follow
uh this project also
so let's let's go back and see what what
can be done so there are two um
analysis that we can actually perform
based on the 16s rrna
amplicon sequencing data here one is
data to pipeline or generally which is
referred to as data true
right and
this this okay here also we have steps
to download this dataset from the buyer
project that's fine so in this
guidelines to running the pipeline
we go through several of the steps that
is involved in setting up this pipeline
in turbo bio info platform
we will quickly go through uh talbot
bion4 platform also
while
while
giving you access for this if you have
access to
this platform and if you
if you can sign up sign into this
platform if you have credentials to get
into this platform please open up
server dot
t bio info let me give that link and
yeah if you go here and then you can
find a
login
option here and login to your
to your profile and irrespective of
whether you have
paid access or not you should be able to
access the demo pipelines what we call
as
pipelines that will help you
our
experimental setup that will help you or
give you an experience of setting up
such
analysis pipeline in the server and
access all the output files that we
provide you for free so that you can
understand
what you will get when trying to
run a pipeline like this so let's go
back to the focus on
on the data to pipeline where we
yes here so we need specifically three
uh types of data and what are the data
that we need and where can you access
that access the data it's actually
focused on here so um
this the project that is associated with
this red syndrome paper is uh is
actually given in in this specific link
and this actually shows
what to download how to find the raw
fastq files right
from the
from the sra database of nih and how to
find relevant information we don't only
need the first your files but we also
need some
relevant
characteristics and information
that we need to input in the
pipeline for the analysis and we can
actually focus on how to prepare three
files that is absolutely necessary to
run
this metagenomics pipeline analysis one
the input fastq files
right that is
that is given as a list of accession ids
that our server is capable of
downloading straight away from the ncbi
and if you are running it uh
independently in your computer you have
to download these gbs and gbs of ascii
files and then try to run it in your
computer or in another environment that
is one and the second is a metadata
which contains a list of characteristics
of your samples and most often our
samples will be
the sequencing of our samples will be
performed under different conditions and
different characteristics for the
samples the samples can be characterized
based on for example
as you can see here
for example
based on different severity level of the
disease based on
they have all sorts of information which
will not be useful in segregating the
samples but some of them like based on
collection date are based on if it is
performed in different
locations and those will also be there
and if it is for example performed
for different phenotypical conditions or
dc state that is the information that we
need to take from this metadata and put
it into a metadata file right that file
actually gives a
list of what are the samples and what
are the different conditions that we
need to relate to those samples right
this samples have healthy control
compared to red syndrome patients and
they are organized as this host disease
is the
host this is the column that gives us
access to this specific biological
condition from this metadata information
so these two um
files that we definitely need not the
two i mean for the other one we need the
barcode but only for the data to
pipeline we need only these two
okay with these two we need it and
[Music]
the next we have guidelines to run the
pipeline you upload these files
right both these files and then start
preparing this pipeline there are
instructions to what to find in what
which area
of these
bio project and
for example we need the read length of
the first few files and based on which
we based on which the pipeline
determines the
overlapping
levels of the otus right forward and
reverse rates of the voter use that is
needed and we need
under what condition we are going to
study um
for example the
abundance level so we we
have our samples separated based on the
disease state that we actually just
discussed and we have to focus on um
mentioning that we want to study the
diseased state of the samples and
the
population microbial population
differences owing to the different dc
state that we have to see right once you
set up this pipeline let's go through
the
experience of setting up this pipeline
how many of you have this access and if
you have this access to server 3 by info
i as i mentioned please log in and you
can follow along with me
how to set this analysis up
or is it available to most of you
can i get some answers
if you do not have access right now for
those who don't have access right now i
think you will get um
you can sign up those who have signed up
in the learn omixlogic portal then you
will get access within 24 hours and you
can
perform these analysis as i have
described here or after also you can
also
get access to the recording of this
of this lecture and
follow along with me so what i wanted to
showcase is under the metagenomics
section right we have
options to perform
the general metagenomics
shotgun metagenomics analysis and we
have options to perform amplicon
sequencing uh analysis and uh an
analysis using kind of right so under
this amplicon sequencing we want to
we don't have that here
okay we don't have the red syndrome
project here for some reasons
if okay i don't think we we have red
syndrome projects here so malik is here
she can
help me out
we don't have red syndrome projects in
data too sonalika that's okay
okay that's enough we can see that okay
can i yeah okay
i'm struggling with some of the floating
meeting controls of the zoom okay so uh
let's
generally irrespective of what data that
we use let's set up a data to pipeline
the
aim is to give you
introduction to how this pipeline can be
set up and what can you access from here
so this is how a pipeline for amplicon
sequencing using data to analysis will
look like right
the this is called the demo pipeline
because we have actually uploaded all
the in necessary input files and you
will get an experience of setting up
this pipeline from the start to the end
as suggested by the suggestions that is
been highlighted so first you have to
start with the start so obviously when
you are setting up this analysis by
yourself you will not start with the
star the start button as
explained in this lesson you will go
through step by step procedure of
selecting the parameters that define
your input files and you will upload the
input files and prepare your input files
or
complete all the
preliminary
uploading and setting up of this input
area before starting let's assume that
we have done that and we have actually
done it and let's go you start with that
and then we go to filtering of
our reads based on quality control that
which will actually eliminate some of
the leads which does not find its
partner and some of the reads which will
not overlap
with the specific read link that we
actually mentioned under
under these uh yeah under the base
length so these are all different uh
parameters that will help us eliminate
some of these which are not going to be
very informative right
we go through
several of these pipelines
steps that will involve denizing that
will involve merging of the forward and
reverse pair and then
once that is achieved that will actually
calculate the otus and cluster the otus
and prepare them for calculating
abundance level so once the cluster is
actually um when the clustering is
actually performed and the otus are
actually defined and then we have to
remove chimeras which are actually
otus that contains more than one type of
specific sequences and then after
cleaning up
your
data the next step is to relate that or
to assign tax on a taxonomy to all of
these otus based on their uh based on
this
based on the real sequences or based on
the sequences that has been done
based on the
sequences that you find in your first
fight so after this
what happened suddenly
okay
i think it's not responding for me for
some reasons
so we'll go over it one more time
it stop responding from the suddenly
so we go for this again
so this is the pipeline you have to
perform some of these analysis in such a
pipeline which will convert your first q
files which are
unstructured uh digital data biological
data into structured tables right the
table that you get yeah exactly so after
assigning pipeline we have to
estimate the phylogeny of these otus
which is required for calculating some
of the
diversity
incidences or instances of your samples
and then we can go for phyloseq analysis
we will discuss more about what
philosophy is um
no volume
am i not audible
to you
can anybody confirm
geoma actually mentions there is no
volume
can somebody confirm my am i audible
yes thank you very much for confirmation
yeah maybe uh legion you have to check
your microphone or the settings okay so
then we have to perform we can actually
operate data visualization uh
which will uh which i will demonstrate
shortly and then we can end the pipeline
so at the end of pipeline what we
actually get is we have actually we will
actually
successfully uh managed to take the
fastq files which are digital data of
our biological sample but in
unstructured format why in unstructured
format uh because they are just a bunch
of reads in sequences and organizing as
organized as several files right we
cannot perform any statistical analysis
on that before converting that into some
sort of table or some sort of list so
this is what the pipeline does that
exactly it takes those unstructured data
and then converts that into a structured
data where we have actually identified
operational taxonomic units and their
taxon
taxonomical associations and
also the abundance levels of these
different taxons or otqs present in our
samples but yeah for for our samples for
different at the different levels so we
have the abundance levels here for
different samples and different otus
mentioned in the rows and samples on the
columns
so this is a structured data we can take
this structure data and perform several
statistical analysis based on which we
can understand the
samples and their
differences so what are these analysis
that we can perform so some of the
results of this analysis is actually
given here we can for it for instance
perform
do we have that information here
we can perform ah
come down results yes
yes so we can perform
visualization in terms of
pca plots right we can perform principal
component analysis to see how samples
from red syndrome and how samples from
healthy control differ in terms of
in terms of principal components that is
calculated for more data and we can take
this in the interactive 3d
principle components also pcf not also
all of this will you will get access
here so this is plot2 2d and for 3d are
the pca 2d and 3d and then another
result that we will get is
taxonomical abundance bar plot this is
what you will mostly associate with
many of the micro metagenomics
paper research papers that you will see
if you see
if you read any of the metagenomics of
the such paper this or rather
proportionate abundance bartlett are is
the
plot that you will
find in many of these associated
resources with the help of interactive
platform like
plotly we can actually get some
interactiveness to our data and
this is actually
implemented in this taxonomical
abundance about what a relative
abundance of this taxa if you click that
it is going to open another tab and they
say
bar plot is going to load up here uh
you can try that when you have chance
i'm not going to do that it's going to
take a while and since i'm presenting
and sharing the screen it's going yes
okay it's already here this is for a
different data that is that is why i'm
not focused on this so let's go back to
the data that we are currently
discussing
yeah so here we can see some of our
associations uh of the samples and their
difference in the abundance level that
you can see so in addition to this what
can you get right
these are all the interactive outputs
that you will get from the data to
pipeline that we have and in addition to
this this pipeline will also give you a
list of pipeline output files which you
can download and there are some
plots like
plots in the pdf format
that will help you understand the
diversity a measure in terms of cow or
chow in terms of shannon diversity
measures right
generally it is going to help you
find patterns of diversity levels inside
samples alpha diversity is a diversity
level that you measure inside each and
every sample so inside for example
these different samples what is the
absolute number of diversity which is
given in the shannon and what is what is
the relative number of
relative diversity level
index or diversity number for for
different microbial population which is
given by
so you can see that take this and see if
there is any pattern that is evolving or
that is emerging
from these
that will differentiate these red
dots from the
green dots so that we can try to
understand the diversity and its effect
and this effect in on or on its
impact in the
deceased state generally so this
in addition to this you will also get
for example
what is
[Music]
uh phylogeny plots and we will also get
uh other uh photogenetic tree plots and
we will also get
tabular information abundance table and
taxonomy table right we will speak
little bit more about
these tables that are part of these
output files when we are going to
discuss how to perform more or how to
take these output files and use it in an
environment like r or python to
have little bit more about this
customization so right now with these
interactiveness we get um
defined customization of our
data right we have interactiveness to
our output files and we have i mean we
have some other
[Music]
picture output or image
output which you can try to under take
it and try to
interpret in terms of the disease
relation and we can try to see the
abundance level of
several different
taxa i think this is
under
class yeah this is under class level of
abundance and their abundance level you
can see that and i can see i can see
some emerging trends like for some of
them we have these bacteria dt's at
higher number so for some of them we
have this bacterial disease as a lower
number so you can relate that to the
deceased state or the healthy state of
the samples and
understand so this is what data two
pipeline offers you um but we don't stop
right here so this gives you one layer
of uh understanding uh your metagenomics
data and also with uh provided with
several um
interactiveness that will help you
generally in understanding the
um
patterns in your data related to the
diseased state or healthy state but we
also have another uh pipeline kind to
pipeline which
uses the advantages of kind to
kind
algorithm
basically this chime algorithm is is a
is a wrapper around the data algorithm
so uh it it takes a lot of this output
from the data to analysis and then gives
you a way to visualize these output
files
when they are
specially organized as time object right
or time
encapsulated data we will see about that
also time encapsulated data and how this
is actually implemented in the server by
enforcement
so
by using kind to analysis we have a
couple of advantages so one of the i
mean this um
the setup and the input file follows
exactly the same right and uh but
the processing or the pipeline actually
differs uh in setting up what needs to
be done let's go over the pipeline one
more time here
so if you go to the tower by info
platform while running the pipeline i'll
tell you what are the advantages time
actually provides we were talking about
that
if you come down to metagenomics kind
too
and here in the demo red syndrome you
will see that quickly check if the chat
is fine
so here also we have uploaded all the
necessary input files and for crime i
think you need uh
yeah the metadata and also the input
these files
uh yeah and leave these two only require
these two files and let's start setting
up the python again all the input files
are uploaded and it is ready to setup
when we start
and at each and every step
you get a preview or you get a short uh
[Music]
of what this specific stage
of this analysis is actually doing right
one of the advantages that actually kind
produces of time gives you is to define
what they call
as
in addition to
operational taxonomic unit they call as
amplicon sequence variance right
osv
which is not limited to
97 percentage or 99 percentage of this
but you can extend that to 100
percentage of sequence identity and then
have higher resolution
of your data that can discriminate
between several
classes if you have a sequences sequence
if you have performed sequencing with
very high depth then you can take this
increased
definition of
what
several
amplicon variants actually consist of
for taxonomic unit actually consists of
right this will take
these
input files and perform a data to
analysis and then again they will go
through silva classification of your
sequencing to associate these otus with
the taxons or taxonomies and then it
will go ahead to remove some unwanted
taxon taxonomy like some of them which
are not defined in the silver or some of
them which have more than one
type of sequences there
and
we have to remove them
and then we can
use
make we can perform some phylogeny
perform phylogenetical analysis is
actually very
important for calculating for estimating
some of the distances that will help us
in um
in estimating or in actually
calculating the beta diversity of our
population right
that is why phylogeny is actually
required
it's a required step
then we can
take some core metrics
like uh the distance metrics or like
separation plots like principal
component analysis or
nmds plot or pcoa plot which will which
are some of the non-linear methods pci's
are linear methods and non-linear
methods of trying to identify separation
in your samples as described as
uh as evidence from your data based on
either the deceased state compared to
the healthy state or based on for
example some of the phenotypical
characteristics most of the time it is
based on the condition under which the
sample is extracted uh etcetera right
but we can see if our data is successful
enough in separating or identifying the
separation in the sample that is
reflected here
and then we also perform radifaction
analysis
if you have this okay we have this graph
that's good so the rarefaction analysis
actually
plots the number of otus that you that
you get against the sequencing depth so
what this what we actually needs what we
actually
need is our data
to attain
a stable um plateauing of uh
in this graph so which will actually
give us an indication of whether or not
we have sequenced our data with
sufficient uh sequencing right uh
sequencing depth so if you have a data
like this
we have insufficient uh sequencing depth
or insufficient number of reads to
describe the diversity as some of the
some of the vote u's are not actually
emerging based on what we are actually
sequencing so this is also very
important so we can get the rail
fraction analysis done and based on this
analysis we can define or we can
actually
make some of the changes to our
sequencing
effects right and then we again
calculate the alpha diversity
visualization that we know we spoke
about this
and we we get some information here and
beta diversity visualization is also
performed
so okay this is not the plot but we will
learn a little bit about beta diversity
parts in in the next session also and
then we opt for interactive
visualization which i will demonstrate
now and let's quickly end it some of the
visualization options that we have to do
and after ending i want you to point out
the fact that look how um
look at the color coding of our of these
steps that involve starting or
pre-processing or main processing or
mapping the sequences or identifying
these
sequence commonalities or identities and
then performing uh some of some of more
downstream analysis and then performing
visualization of our um
no not downstream analysis performing um
or estimating the counts or estimating
or converting these data into structural
data structural
uh structured format and then performing
downstream analysis based on the
structure table and then ending it right
we follow this color coding in all the
uh
ngs sequencing data analysis in this
throughout the board by infrastructure
so now a noticeable change in the output
files is we have only one option and we
do not have multiple options and what
this one option is actually giving you
is is an external dashboard
that you can click and
let it load
and this external dashboard will
actually take care of some of the
changes that you want to perform to your
downstream apps remember in the previous
data to pipeline which will also get
this dashboard very soon right
that interactive that interactive output
will help you in some interactiveness
but you cannot change any parameters
there but this dashboard will actually
help you not only in
in the same interactiveness but also it
will change the parameters like i mean
at the basic level i can change the
visual appeal
right
this is going to change the bars
language and make it a little bit more
visual and at more uh yeah level i can
change the type of color
right to make it more distinct and at
more functional level i can choose of
the metadata or of the taxonomic level
under what grouping do i want to see
this abundance plot i mean this is this
is done for
for what actually for family and let's
see
does it change anything if we do it for
phylum
so
obviously for phylum level of
interpretation this data hardwares
or this data is has more resolution
in terms of in terms of their otus and
hence the phylum level is actually going
like giving you a bird's eye view of
what you can get but for some of the
other data analysis like that involves
the data too and other ones maybe phylum
is a pylon level uh
proportionate abundance understanding is
is actually very helpful so let's go to
again family family is what we were
dealing with yes we can go to one more
level let's see if um at genus level
does it have anything
yes you see more population genius level
but the problem with
genus level and species level is this
right
we have this other group which is
predominant right so for most of the
bacterial population generally the
taxonomic rank
does not have well-defined genus so that
is why if you want to study the
abundance level of this microbial
population it's a good idea or it's a
good practice to go at higher taxonomic
ranks from genius level right at family
level order level etcetera right
so that is why people stick to family
order or file a level of
taxonomic rank so so this gives you this
difference right but this is not
possible in in the earlier data to
pipeline and
once we have this interactiveness built
into that that's also awesome okay what
do we have here here we have the
nmds or metric uh
dimensional scaling of our data right
and we can actually color this
by different ah
difference in the um
um what do you call that
the meta information file that we
actually uh
inputted right that these are the
columns that is found in the sample
characteristics metadata that we
uploaded right and several of these as
we actually discussed is not very
informative but some of them will be
very very informative like we can
we first have to color right our basic
understand idea is to see if there is
any separation based on our data between
red syndrome and healthy control so
let's do the coloring according to that
yes so we have the coloring according to
that and see and
not much of a separation but there are
some
red syndrome patients which have some uh
which deviate from the central the
central cluster centrality of the
cluster and more samples from red
syndrome actually deviate can i zoom out
this one i don't know
i think again
more of the red syndrome patient uh
samples are actually
coming away from this specific from this
from this cluster than the uh
healthy control so that is one of the
observation that we find in the nmds you
can add one more layer of separation
based on the type of symbol that is used
let's see if there is any correlation
between the red syndrome separation or
from the separation of the sample and
for example body mass index right bmi
for this
maybe not this is not very relevant
and maybe for okay bmi has
several parameter so it is actually um
giving you changes in the
sizes and this one
types of
knot sizes types of
shape depending on the bmi let's find a
simpler
one maybe
do they have epileptic crisis yes or no
yes we have epileptic crisis yes or no
so that will take care of uh the shape
and
yeah there is there are only looks like
squares what are the squares one square
is here okay so this is what you will
get so this kind of
changing your
parameter that defines the
annotation of the nmds plot is possible
only in the dashboard and it is not
possible well while you are setting up
the pipeline analysis right so it is
good to have
and
that is your answer whether you can zoom
or not so in the diversity plot right
this is just a count what you can do is
you can select under what category you
want to group this again my primary
focus is to find whether or not i find a
differences in the diversities of my
observed samples for healthy control
so for this i see that there is a
difference in um there is a difference
of distribution in
red syndrome versus healthy control
samples so that i can now see that
the abundance level of red syndrome or
the diversity i believe is higher for
the red syndrome compared to the healthy
control so
that
will straight away yeah
this is this is this has to be done for
specific
at specific abundance level and uh this
plot right now does not produce you uh
diversity estimated from shannon or cow
or chow uh diversity levels um diversity
indices but that will be up
updated soon so soon in this interactive
visual dashboard you will see diversity
plots like the one that we discussed
what is this
in the pdf file
i discussed in the pdf file do we have
it here
no
yes
in the previous pdf file which gives you
alpha and shannon
shannon and the chao diversity alpha
diversity for different
samples so this will be populated with
that and then you can actually use that
for uh
but uh in addition to this time what
actually
says uh let's go back to the output
right in addition to uh
interactive dashboard it actually gives
you
all the uh
kind visualization and time analysis of
one thing i forgot to tell you
let's let's load up the dashboard again
so the dashboard also gives you a table
of i mean based on what you how you can
download the data right this is a table
that you also have access to this table
from
this output files but you can download
this table from this output files and uh
yeah
and use
for example
download data yeah and use that use this
table to
uh your own code or your own downstream
analysis that we will discuss now and um
and and
make some changes like if you want to
change the color or if you want to
change some other ah
some other part of the representation
you can do that this is
so this is how you can produce
quality output files or that will help
you in interpreting
the
abundance level
differences between
this specific case right which can which
deals with healthy control and
red syndrome patients
so if you have yeah i was talking about
time
data right
so these files will actually give you q
is at v and q is a file
so they are actually chime objects
right these chime objects can be loaded
up into this
chime
interface kind view interface and you
can drop these funds here
where is this
okay i think i have downloaded several
of them here
and let's take a look at one of them
like this for example this body side
significance which is a
yeah this is beta diversity
fraction of body significance right so
this immediately will produce you the
significance plot of course this is not
going to be as rich as what we have seen
here but this is a good start right so
uh this is the added advantage of time
to analysis which is a wrapper around
the data to analysis itself right
one it actually enables you to get more
resolution by defining
very high
threshold levels for
for otus and asps right and
also it produces you
these visualization files which you can
load it up into kind to viewer
so that you can view them
these visualization files are nothing
but
zipped files you can
unzip this right q zv you simply open it
with archive utility so you can unzip
this and then or access how the data is
actually arranged for those who are
more into
getting the table out of this data so
you can go through this this is the json
files and we have the tabular tsv file
from this so this is the tsv file so we
have done this download and we have done
this cleaning up of this file from q s q
z v objects and
that is what you get access to in this
table
in addition to this this is what you
will also get access to in some of the
tables that you find here
okay so that is about how to perform
meta genomics analysis in a completely
code free environment
you can get high quality graphics and
high quality which will enable you to
interpret uh your day your results to
the complete level and
that will maybe
help you in more
experimental decisions and also in in
the story that you are building
in trying to understand the effect or
impact of metagenomics data analysis for
the disease that you are studying if you
have any questions until now and this is
the time that you can ask questions
until um
before we move on to how to perform a
doubt this downstream analysis from some
of the tables that you are going to you
can download um from this pipeline
output files and load it up into a an r
environment
right and
etcetera right that we can quickly
discuss now so if you have any questions
until now this is the time and please
enter type your questions in the chat
box
if you do not have any questions then we
will proceed
i will set up my sharing again
okay let's find my
shoe
huh
can you see my screen please confirm
somebody
yes perfect uh linda yes that i will
actually come here the the index code or
the
setting up of taxa for uh for phylogeny
uh
is actually not based on what you want
to study right i mean in a way
what do you
mean by the index code into the taxa
i don't understand what you mean by the
index code in the text but usually what
that's how taxonomy is actually done why
taxonomy is actually studied is ah
to for example to eliminate some of the
leaves or some of the clades that does
not have enough population to uh
yeah
to influence the distance metrics that
are that are uh estimated for a beta
diversity estimation by beta diversity
population
parameter that is distributed so we will
discuss a little bit more about taxonomy
and how they can if you want to go into
such specific into accessing
that particular aspect of
changing the level of taxonomy or
changing what percentage of
otus that that that is going to
contribute to
towards um characterizing your
phylogenetic tree then you have to do a
focused uh downstream analysis in r or
in python r is more suited for that
why i will discuss now and uh um
so that you have more flexibility
generally right that is that is why it
is there and
for those who wanted to understand
generally
the code free environment with the
interactive dashboard is sufficient for
you to even produce
extremely high quality graphics for your
research projects and and for
publication also
so if you
want very specific tweaking right then
for example and now at this point of
implementation that is not possible in
the
in the
dashboard maybe in future if the
functionality of the dashboard expands
to all the areas then you will get
access to that also but right now let's
focus on how to expand
ah rosina that's an excellent question
we have a question from rosina who says
can the pipelines be run using nanopore
data currently all of the pipeline
methods are actually restricted to using
illumina data all right unfortunately uh
nanopore are long read sequencing data
is not sub
is not supported
where we are taking the first two files
and making them uh performing mapping
nanopore data is not actually supported
but when you have produced uh this
mapping and have produced a
structured table or list of variants or
other
tabular data then you can
use lot of other tools in the platform
to perform
complex
downstream analysis and machine learning
analysis and other statistical analysis
for your any type of data changing right
that is what you can do but currently
nepal data is not
supported
okay let's go ahead again
so this we saw the red syndrome can this
be discussed and now in order to tell
you how you can use an environment like
r
to understand for example
uh how metagenomics is uh used to
study the role of high fat diet on a pct
level right um that can be performed or
that can be
that is actually studied in a model
system like mouse
some of the basic advantages of using a
model system as opposed to
collecting or studying data from human
cases
we will definitely see
experience in this
in this demo also
but if you remember our
diversity plot our alpha diversity plot
of
our red syndrome
samples versus ld samples everything was
all over the place
right this is mainly because
data from human subjects are are not
noise free or in other words the signal
in that data is actually buried deep
inside so it's any
uh straightforward analysis is going to
throw up a lot of noise so it takes a
lot of
trial and error and
and
isolation or maybe more number of
samples to bring out that signal that we
want to uh study in from the human
data but for a controlled environment
like a mouse sample or
in this case
we can actually do away with several of
the samples but focused uh focus on
on smaller number of samples and perform
very high quality research from
controlling the environment that will
influence for example in in this study
right which studies the role of high-fat
diet right it actually tries to find
more and more evidences for the
establishment or for the existence of
gut brain access what they call right
the changes in the microbiome uh is will
actually effect is not the is not also
just straightforward association will
actually affect the behavioral
aspects of the host right that is what
the aim
by
treating the mice to antibiotic
treatment
we can completely clean up their
microbial environment in their gut and
then we can supplement these mice
supplemented supplemental microbiota
from other mice that take high fat diet
or normal diet and and see whether the
cleaned mice's behavior actually alters
or changes
because of the supplementation so that
is the experimental setup such a high
precision level experimental setup is
not possible for human condition for
obvious reasons we can neither clean
away our
microbial population nor perform similar
analysis so but for environment control
environment like mice we can do that so
we
give the antibiotic to completely
eliminate the bacterial load of the
pesticides and then we supplement these
mice not with the high fat diet but the
microbiota that is developed for mouse
which took high fat diet and the
microbiota uh samples or fecal samples
from that mice is actually implemented
into these cleaned up mice and again
ciao is a normal diet okay microbiota
from chow
mice is actually supplemented to this
mice and see
if there is any behavioral changes
in the mice that take high fat diet and
that took chao that's it experimental
setup so
for this let's see uh
how we can set up the data to pipeline
we already spoke about how to perform
data to pipeline so i'm not going to
go over the details again one more time
so let's quickly stop sharing here and
go to the
associated lessons
and meanwhile while i am setting up
sharing we have
how to select precision or particular
antibiotic medication for patients using
metagenomics i'll come back to your
question palat right right now it's it
will deviate from current topic of uh
discussion so i do not want to focus on
that right now so i will come back to
your basic definition
so hope you can see my screen so this is
for the
can you see my screen i do not get
confirmation
from zoom
if you can confirm that will be great
yes thank you very much usually there is
a green box that tells me which is
shared but it's not okay so this is the
um
lesson or projects example a project
that deals with this role of high-fat
diet in obesity for now so you can see
how to set up these analysis
for this so
for the purpose of this specific uh
um
webinar right these two lessons right
our code lesson six and seven is
actually unstacked you can see the star
uh
which
which means that the access is limited
to the paid customers so this is for you
so if you have um access to this or if
you have a signed up for learner mixed
logic platform please open up your
this lesson i'm going to give you this
link
right
so we saw that let me
everyone so this is the
this is a
this is the
web link that i am
currently viewing so if you are signed
up into the omixlogic platform if you
click on this link it will take you to
the lesson if you are not signed up it
will take you to the home page so sign
up in
sign in or log in and then click on this
it will take you
so from the output from the data to
pipeline output files we need
three tables right all of these three
tables we already got some introduction
into the otu or the abundance table
which actually gives us
the abundance level of all the vote use
that is estimated from our input data
and the taxonomy table which actually
relates these otus through two different
taxon ranks of the bacteria or the
microbes estimated from the silver data
and the metadata table which which will
actually relate the sample and the
different conditions under which the
sample is studied
these three are the necessary files that
we need to know and while we are also
loading we will use the um
google cola right collab uh
environment to perform this analysis in
r or you can also do this perform this
analysis and
and let's see if we can do that
yes perform this analysis in the try it
yourself section where we gave you our
uh console so that we can perform these
analysis here right
okay
so for for the sake of this one we will
use google collab and what do we need to
do so this is after downloading this
data into your computer and then you can
perform this analysis in r that is
installed in your computer or you can
perform this analysis in google
collaboratory
uh open the collab notebook in r and how
to do that is
um
okay uh
collab.2.art is not working for some
reasons right now
yeah this one collaboratory language r
okay this open this up if you are here
everybody
please open this up quickly
if you open this you are going to get a
page like this
little low
so this is the environment right in
spite of this saying ipynb this is an r
environment where you can run
our codes um with the help of
google host time that is that is given
to you free right if you have google
account we can easily do this and we can
so
everybody who is interested please open
up this page and in this page
first what you have to do is to connect
right press connect and if you connect
it is going to convert or is going to
change into this um
icon right connected icon which
allocates you some resources to run
right
if you are done there
let me give an s give me an s and then
while we will explore the usage of
google collab as we go
okay i've actually done it and then yeah
yes okay let's go to here and i want you
to install some of the packages which is
a philosophy package which is a specific
package
for
metagenomics or micro meta genomics
downstream analysis in r so copy this
code and put it
in your code block the first block that
you will see is a code block right if
you don't see anything you can use this
and open up a block and double click
inside that and paste
you will see
something like this inside your code
block
you won't see the install package but
you will see something like
this right
you will see something like this and if
your cursor is blinking inside this and
you can paste it like this this is what
i want you to have
if you have this and then press this
specific
greater than symbol
if you press this then you will start
installing the necessary package
i can't see okay you can see my google
collab page
can can people see my
screen
what are you no okay whatever i'll stop
and try again what are you seeing
actually
funny okay
let's stop and share again for some
reasons it is not
okay now can you see something
t bioinfo server yeah okay thank you
okay so this is okay uh
if you open up your google collab i
think uh you can did you follow until
where i told you how to connect or you
could not follow that also
there's a connect option right here
where i see my thick green tick so you
will see connect there so press or tap
on the connect that is going to assault
allot you some resources
and after that you will see
a box like this if you see a box like
this then copy the course that i gave
you
it's right here
and paste it inside that box
so like what i'm doing right now
and then
tap on this or press this run cell
option
if you do that i have already done it so
i'll get an output like this which is
going to install packages that is
specific for that is
that we need for running this analysis
so just quickly let me know if you have
done it
and it has completed installation
yes for me so somebody has completed
installation so
can i see some of couple of faces so
that we can proceed
so for by the way for the codes that i
am taking or for the codes that i'm
actually discussing they are actually
given in these
uh
lessons right associated lessons that we
are discussing downstream analysis in r
so this is see that this is a code block
that i took
from there and gave it to you
and for the next piece i'm going to take
this code load required libraries
so again you can also do that if you
follow along if you have this lesson
you can follow along
and you can take this code specifically
and then
put it
right open up another
cell how to open up another cell you are
going to be here or somewhere here
you want the okay course link i will
provide you with the course link in just
a moment so in this cell
after this you can
open up a new code cell below this by
pressing this code plus core option here
so use plus code option you will get
another one and paste your library and
then again run the cell
right for those who wants the code
course link it is right here
the course link is right here
okay let's go back here quickly
so after this it's going to give you
output like this everybody
install the packages and have everybody
loaded the packages
you will get i mean if you have you will
get uh the credentials very soon it
actually it usually takes 24 hours for
you to get the credentials we have to
send you
credentials so you will get it very soon
so if you have installed
less than 24 hours ago you will
wait have to wait for your
t bio info server credentials we have to
allocate and give it okay
okay so uh after this
is done so we have to now load the input
file same three input files that we
spoke about so all the three input files
they are actually
given in this
link
i'm not going to go over
how r actually loads the data table into
our syndrome which is very
straightforward i would suggest you to
go through some of the r lessons in our
course uh in our omixlogic platform so
this is again as i am going to take it
from there
load the input section in
in here right here exactly right here so
what so what r actually does is while
you are loading up i'll tell you what r
actually does is it uses a function read
dot table to read any tabular
information and then
take it and then put it into an object
that we call as data frame data frame is
a collection of um
is a table which contains collection of
different types of data types different
types of data for example
in a matrix you can store only numerical
data in an array you can store only one
type of data that data can be
numerical or logical or characteristic
but it is restricted to one time but in
a data frame you can combine a numerical
data in one column followed by a logical
data in another column followed by ah
character data in another column which
is very helpful for us to organize
the lab organize our data in the level
that we want right that is that's a data
frame so the read.table function
takes the location of your file either
online as given here or from your local
computer as you will just
define and then loads it up into a data
frame that we are calling as what um
this is a redirection or assignment
operator in r language which takes the
result of this function and then puts it
r
applies or
loads it up into this object so that is
a very short introduction and these are
all some of the parameters that define
the characteristics of our table what
does it say this says that does my
column has a column name that's my first
row is a description of the column names
and if it is true let's say true and how
are the columns in my input table
separated are they separated by comma or
are they separated by tab so this is a
table that is separated by tab so i am
giving the tab character backslash t is
attached so this is what we have done if
you have done until here please
respond yes and if you run this you are
not going to get any
you are not going to get any
confirmation it's going to just run and
then finish just like what i have done
you will see a green tick mark on your
left side here i have not done this also
i have to run this
for this yes you will see a green tick
mark on the side
and if you have done this you will see
another green tick mark on the side if
you are done quickly respond to me you
have to hurry up
okay
respawn everybody loaded the input files
or most of you are through with the
loading the input files
yes perfect
one more a couple of more yeses i can
get only one
so what do we have in the next other few
options are if you are true with r you
can go ahead so we can visualize the
loaded input files like that's what the
head command does we can visualize first
few lines of the loaded input file so
that is what here is
we can take this and
so you can visualize this what do you
get if you visualize you'll get first
few lines of your input files first you
get the first few lines of the otu table
so as we've said the otu table contains
the sample names
and it also contains of otu on the rows
the otus are organized in the rows and
the sample names are organized in the
columns
and we will also get the taxonomy table
right tax matrix that has taxonomy table
that is loaded here so where we will see
each and
uh yeah
you will get you will get the recording
right
we will discuss about recording later um
so this is the taxonomy table that we
obtained from silva database that is
going to associate your otus
right to specific taxonomy you see that
we have
otu1 assigned to this specific bacterial
identities phylum and this specific
family right as i as we discussed
for many of these bacterial population
the genus and species are not determined
yet and for those we have the not
applicable values for those for which we
have then we have their levels populated
and that is why it is useful to perform
some of the
grouping from the family and upwards not
focus on genes and species
and then we have the metadata right
metadata samples they have which have
two
information or two main sources this is
first few lines we have
21 samples and we have this description
for all of this
it says what is the sample and what kind
of diet the sample takes and what is the
source of the sample whether the source
sample is from the fecal data or so the
sample is from the sql data right
and then we have to pre-process the data
right for preprocessing what do you mean
um for example this is a data frame as
we said but data frame is very good for
loading up the data organizing the data
and keeping record of your data in arts
and environment but many of the
statistical analysis
are performed on on uh matrix kind of
data so our data contains character
information in the first column and
numerical information in the other
column so we have to get rid of this
character information and store it
somewhere so that is what this
row i mean preprocessing actually does
and they also stores some of the other
preprocessing
other information like the sample names
sample types are also stored separately
so this is what we do
and again this code is straight away
from that lesson
okay so when i run this
okay this is what you get and not you'll
get you'll not get any output here and
let's open up another code you can open
up another code from here or if you
hover over here you will get option to
open up another code here also so let's
go to the core and then what do you see
here so i have done the preprocessing
and then i have to transform everything
into matrix form
again okay this is a necessary step and
let's transform everything into a matrix
format
follow along
and then after this do this
okay we have transformed everything into
matrix format and why are we doing this
we you will get to know right and uh
this is where we are actually coming to
fight
we need to take these and
convert that into a phyloseq object
so philosophy gives you a keynote of
your eagle eye right let this copy this
and i'm going to change it
and while you are running this run all
of these and you will get no output
but eagle-eyed viewers and participants
will see that we have installed a
library called filosek as i said filed
and loaded this one up right finosek is
the library that performs this meta
genomics analysis and several of the
standard analysis is actually embedded
into this finalistic library
and to perform that analysis all these
three tables that we have loaded from
three different files and loaded into
three different
objects data frames and pre-processed
test has to be unified into one
phyllosic object
right that is performed using the steps
five and six which takes or which
defines an otu table in filo seeks
language and defines a
table in again in 506 understanding
language and defines a sample data in
506 understanding language right this is
necessary to build a philosophic object
which we will use which only that object
we will use for performing all the
analysis method and many of these
analysis methods are automated inside
this pylosic library which is going to
be very helpful for us right
ok so what do we do after
defining what is otu table taxonomic
tickle table and sample data to the
filosic library and we build a phylo
seek object we unify this into a
phylosec object that is what we get here
and let's do that
and please follow it along and i know
i'm rushing because we don't have enough
time we are literally past the time so
after this
so the first line is actually unified
going to unify all of this into a
pilosik object which we are naming as a
physique object and if i am printing out
the information inside i seek object
this is what you will see
for those who know little bit of r the
type of data is a class right our class
data type and that has different
information in it by go to utable sample
data taxonomical
table all of them and their specific or
respective dimensions are given here
our otu table is actually 474
um
otus long what to use
long and
20 samples wide and our sample data is
actually again as we have for 20 samples
we have two association one is the kind
of diet that the samples take and and
two is a
source from which the diet is one either
fecal or c and then the taxonomic table
has these 474 votes associated with
seven taxonomic banks starting from
kingdom until class
no
species yeah so okay so what do we do
with this fellowship object so far we
have pre-processed and packaged the data
in such a way that the filosic library
will understand
and then we can again this i am going to
skip but what this is going to produce
is something like this
we can actually access
um
okay this is different
yeah okay we can actually access uh
where is this
it's a number of samples ah okay we have
the output also here the number of
samples again some of the specific
information from this dimension and what
are the sample sums which is going to
give you how many different
number of
reads or files that is present for each
and every one of these samples or reads
for sample that you can get from sample
sums and then the number of taxa and
then what are the different variants
sample variables that we are dealing
with and different taxonomic rank so now
until now we have pre-process the data
and package the data and for the data
visualization
again we can start from simple
bar plot i mean but visualization at the
file name level uh right and
for example if you take this code and
then
this is a code i'm this code
if you have run all the previous
is going to be eight yeah all the
previous
[Music]
steps then if you run this code this is
going to run properly without any issue
right let's run this code and see
so what this code actually does right
this is the only thing that is required
this code does
it it plots a bar plot and the bar plot
is taking the phylocyc object that we
define and it is actually filling at the
level of phylum if you change this
phylum to genus as defined as or
has exactly defined here with the
capitalization in the first level it's
going to change that so you can you can
try that and what you have in the second
line is a beautification option you give
the size for for the legendary and
legend text and access text and
everything these are all beautification
options right this is absolutely
necessary
so here we get the abundance plot but
not the proportional abundance plot but
the relative abundance plot that we have
so for the proportional abundance plot
again we go down we see here right
[Music]
no we have to calculate the relative
abundance because the abundance as you
can
see from this proportional lab from this
normal abundance plot is not uniform for
some of them it goes from zero to around
six thousand or seven thousand some of
them it goes as high as fifteen thousand
sixteen thousand so we don't know
whether this abundance of uh bacterial
identities that i observe for this
specific bkf21 sample is generally
extremely abundant compared to the other
sample or is proportionately comparable
to the other samples right how do i do
that you can you know that we can easily
do that by comparing
the number of abundances to uh
respective percentages that is what we
are doing here we are transforming the
sample count into
one that is going to reflect into in
personal uh percentages so that we are
going to rename that phyloseq object
into
phyllosic optic that is normalized
this is what you will do
and
when you do that the sample sums are all
will
stop at
100. so if you compare the previous
sample sums
sample sums of
seek object
each one of these sample will have
different samples as you can see here
some go as high as 13 000 and some go as
low as 2000 so all of these are now
normalized to 100 that is what you will
see here and after normalizing to 100 if
you take the same part
and
[Music]
instead of okay what happened here
i did not copy the second part portion
portion
okay instead of file save object you see
normalized
then
if you run
you are going to produce a plot like
this right you can change this level to
[Music]
genus
okay that is not producing the plot
because there is a lot of genus have
information
phylum
okay for this different purposes we have
given a little bit of a different code
in the
lesson right we will see what that code
is and uh
yeah here if you take if you use instead
of um
right if you
you saw the difficulty that i
got when i changed the
phylum level to genius level because of
the restriction in the space
i cannot see the
plot completely right
this is the proportional abundance plot
right
so here it uses the rs basic
bar plot option to perform or to
visualize
uh where i yes we actually installed a
thai dplyr
oh it is not working
i have not used that so far did i use it
so far
i've not used that option so far no
where do you get that
so here
minister
great name
so yeah dplyr will do that reverse or
dplyr will do that right um okay we
don't need to install we just have to
load all the loading packages if you
have loaded that that will work okay
let's come back so
when we change that to genius level some
of the portions are i mean because of
the
label being very big we are not able to
visualize it so for that we have to use
gg plot option to do that and also we
have to define
what is the base genus level or genius
level
here
at this point we can define whether we
want to see this in phylum or genocide
so when we get this
we can copy this and paste it
okay
so when you run this
you will get the exactly the same plot
at the phylum level
and then you can see there differences
and then if i want to see this in the
genus level and i have to just type
genus here
and then you can see
again phyla why
because
here reorder
genus yeah
okay again i'm not able to see this
that's really strange
okay we'll worry about this later
go to file level i think we have to
define
the size of the plots right or yeah the
genus level we can say that legend we
don't need any legend and then we can do
that
in your r if you do that it will work
okay
i can address this in the lessons
in this lesson i will update what do we
know okay here what do we need to do
when we want to change this from these
column
but incidentally because there are too
many genus level we don't want to change
that to genus level we want to go one
step higher this level uh filename level
to class or kingdom or something
somewhere
so then that will work okay
okay so this is this is what we will do
and uh
this downshift analysis for some of the
specific questions that i got right
i'm not going to demonstrate everything
now you get the
you get the hang of
how you can access this so we are going
to uh
i'll ask sanalika to
keep this unstarred for some more at
least one more hour or so we can
practice this and interested people can
sign up and then get access to not only
this to several of the other resources
that is going to help you with this so
and this is by grouping uh these samples
not
observing or not plotting these samples
individually so this plots the samples
at the individual level and this process
samples per the group as we have in the
sample metadata sample metadata has chow
versus h of v you can also change this
group by fecal versus seeker
you can do that and then if you come
down
all of this is going to help you for
example um
yes
yes for
these are the different pre-processing
that you need in order to perform for
example for family level and differences
why we need to do that we need to do
that because when you are going to
perform at the level of family
we are going to have
we are going to rebuild our pyroc
objects because
at the level of family
the number of otus will definitely
decrease so that's what we have to look
at this
now the otu table has only
19 taxes because we are going to define
in terms of family so when we have a
mismatch between the number of otus
defined and the number of otus defined
in the taxonomy table then we will have
problems so when we are going to define
it in the family level so we have to
make this make a new table and also i
have to make a new normalized function
then remember the normalized function is
normalized according to the
general number of abundance of otu
calculated by
the
species level so for the family you have
to redo this again so when you redo this
we can
check or we can define
we can understand the proportional
abundance of hamilton i think this takes
care of the position
bottom will take care of the
display of the plots here so we have to
do that also in the in this uh then we
can we will know we will it will work so
if you take this one
uh
legend position right so we change that
to
let's say genus and here also genus
penis
bottom and then this work
yes so this will work here
this is to do it in the genus level
okay
so uh you get the hang so that that's
what we do so more and more
customization is possible this is this
lesson deals the lesson first lesson for
six lesson six deals with uh creating
these various abundance flaws for
different uh at different levels for
ourselves so we go back and we also have
this try it yourself section where you
can try this
um
by giving these input files here we can
define these input files and
this is the here to challenge you right
the try it yourself section is to test
is to help you
um
evaluate yourself based on your
understanding of these course right what
we have done is we have for example you
can see that we have um
left several
some of the information some of the
codes in this code block empty so if you
run this as such it's not going to run
it's going to throw you an error
yeah yeah it's going to throw you an
error but if you uh convert or if you
take the input files link and just press
the link here and
convert these
or complete these
syntaxes and then it will run let's try
one example
copy link address that's what you have
to do
then in this specific one you have to
paste this
okay and then the second one is taxonomy
cable
link address anyway we're not going to
go over a lot of other ones so
press this then for the third one
copy link address
okay so we have this one ready and then
and then what is missing
transformation into matrix is missing we
actually done that here so let's take it
from here transformation into matrix is
this is missing copy this
okay and then what else is missing do we
have in everything
i think um
[Music]
okay sum up the number of all reads per
sample this is sample sums
and yeah
that is okay
i think when you run this
then it will
yeah not only work but also give you a
feedback the success in running the code
answer is correct okay more uh
specific examples of producing plots are
also available here so you can check it
out and some of the assignments for you
to test yourself is given here that is
specific to this lesson all of these
testing or challenges are
specific to the course that you learned
in this lesson so you can
try that to test your understanding of
what you have done so far so what is
given in the next lesson the next lesson
is where we are going to estimate the
diversity plots for our samples right
this follows the same installation same
required libraries loading and then same
preprocessing of the data then we can
straight away go to the measures of the
diversity so if you have the filosic
object as such and then
copy this and paste it we are going to
get sample diversity so if you are
following along in the google collab
until now even until now
even after all this
time so run this and you will get
the shannon diversity and chow diversity
so that's what you will get here right
and
so this is exactly the plot that
the associated
pipeline produces and this is how you
can produce this here you will get much
more options of identifying some of the
um
i mean you can move this around and you
can change the
width and background everything that you
can customize according to your
necessary right and
and in addition to this you can also get
down
and then
do this richness level at the
yeah
do this richness level at the level of
combined uh plots okay so we will also
we can you can also go through some of
the
associated codes this gives you beta
diversity and generally for beta
diversity we have to visualize the beta
diversity in
[Music]
in more
other options
and yeah and
visualize the beta diversity in the nmds
plot or in pcoa plot right and this beta
diversity measures the distances between
sample based on the abundance level that
is present inside the sample right
and
and yeah for that
you have to calculate the distances for
some of the distances we need to
estimate the
we need to estimate the phylogenetic
plot somebody was discussing about the
phylogeny and this gives you code to
characterize or to
customize the estimation of this
phylogeny for example this
displays only 25 of those phylogenys and
you can change uh change this and top 10
pilots change a lot of these things and
change the level or change the distance
metric that you are defining based on
the phylogeny that you have actually
calculate right you can go through them
all of these course can be accessed and
you can also try yourself out
in this try it yourself section so this
is the advantage of using downstream
analysis in r with a filoseq
so i will conclude the session with this
here and also give you some introduction
to for example
uh this analysis can be performed on
on python also right
but
since the filo sick kind of wrapping up
library is not available in python we
have to do this analysis separately so
in order to do this analysis separately
you have to write some of the codes some
of the extensive codes
in python and we have given i made this
python course also our python license
also free uh where is this if i can
access that
i think here yes
so uh yes
this is also free you can see the level
of coding that is necessary if you are
not going to use
a module like a filo seat that is
designed specifically for handling meta
genomics data you can see that again
preparing the data is going to be
similar and then
when your character is characterizing or
when you are displaying some of the uh
this is an mds plot and coming down here
yeah when you are trying to displaying
the abundance level
for the
for the
samples are otus and this is the level
of coding that is necessary to produce
plots like this plots like this this
code the codes became extensive because
of the code has actually options to
access different taxonomic ranks and
different
orders of the samples and different
levels of this happen so that's why it
became so extensive and also produces
this statistical uh parameter estimation
that is why it is there um but you can
make this code little bit trimmed up if
you want to estimate for specific phylum
taxonomic range and for specific uh this
bacteria
right um
this is in python so people who are
interested in python can
check this
lesson
can
try this lesson out and yeah and get
back to us so if you have any questions
until now uh
please
type it type that out in the chat box
and we will discuss this here if you
have followed it along with the r code
and
if you have this r code you can actually
make this collaboratory notebook in r
also in python the codes
covered in the lessons will also work in
python's r code you can find out how you
can get this python out code and for
registered participants if you need our
feedback in
moderating your r code what you can do
is after
making this
our codes in collab after making this
pull up you can press the share
and then that is going to open up like
this and then give
change this to anyone with the link or
restricted that's fine people and then
add a support at point.bio and
elia.bio to this and then send this to
us
right
please check my
if you have any problem then you can
define problem here itself or different
problems here right how you can make
make us know about the problem
right you can comment
you can comment based on this
if i can select yeah
add a comment
not working
please
so if you can add a comment and then
share this notebook with us then we can
check this and then we will find some of
the changes then point you out in
specific uh satellite
i will maybe reply with syntax error in
this portion please refer to this lesson
or please do this for um so that you can
check okay
okay that's how you can get in touch
with us regarding your collaboratory
notebook and regarding your course
if you have any other queries and
questions this is the right time to ask
if not then i will hand over the stage
back to malika and there was a question
related to precision medicine which i
passed and said i will handle later
how and
if you are still here asked how to
select precision or particular
antibiotic medication for patients using
metagenomics so this is
a very broad topic which involves
comparing the microbial population and
abundance level of the patients compared
to healthy subjects and then see if some
intervention can be done in building up
yes i think i did the project 13 also
here okay building up
this database of comparative okay paste
link to project 13. so what is project
13 okay
oh that's not here
downstream analysis of diversity
measurement is not here okay yeah i
forgot to place the link for the
diversity measurement thank you very
much for reminding me and the stage is
all yours and malakai if you're still
here
i think sonalika is not here and if then
spurs are you here
okay
and then with that i think we will
conclude today's session so interested
people can participate interested people
can sign up
and
you will receive
how to access
several different portions of the comics
logic platform and
and also the portal in separate
orientation session
if you have any other queries please let
me know
okay if you do not have any questions
and then we can
complete the
session or complete the webinars
thank you very much for the
participation
thank you very much rosina
thank you and hope to see you all in the
metagenomics
program that we are going to host in for
thank you very much